Did you know that bees are out there talking to each other right now?
Mm.
The honeybee performs a waggle rotation dance to share information about the
location and distance of a nearby point of interest.
Let's say you're stuck in a beehive and you're friendly,
busy beef goes up foraging on her journey.
She finds a flower full of powdery Pauline.
She heads back to tell you and the rest of the hive where this flower is,
how distance and direction my friend, she makes a waggle run,
shaking it back and forth real fast while she kind of walks in the straight
line. When she gets to the end,
she turns to the left circles back around to the start. Waggle run again.
Now turn to the right back to the start while I go run again.
Turn to the left. You get the idea.
Do we really need like a whole electronic waggle B dance mix?
What's really cool is that the length of this waggle run varies and it varies in
a way that's precisely related to be traveled time,
be travel distance closer to the destination, the shorter the waggle. In fact,
with every second,
a waggle run lasts that B telling you to travel one kilometer. So what?
We have kilometers in miles and bees have Wagga waggles. Okay,
one kilometer ready to go. But go where?
Like a compass up is this bs point of reference,
which is the sun up means towards the Sun.
The angle of the waggle run tells you where to keep the sun in your sky while
you travel. Combine that angle with your distance and you're ready to go.
Other Info might be it actually hiding in this shake and rotate routine like
familiarity, experience.
Bees might pay particular attention to the smell of familiar flower coming off
the dance, or for instance,
or maybe danger with the dancers circling around to do fewer wagon rides.
If the destination is dangerous. Target,
if we compare other bees in other parts of the world,
we even find waggle dialects and the possibility of social learning.
That's a lot to take in.
A little be click to buzz on over to animal communication.
And don't forget to subscribe for language.
[inaudible].